you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with former special adviser to saju
javid salma shah and con mist and
broadcaster steve richards that they
both are so let's see what's on some of
those front pages for you now
the eye leads on covid as ministers push
for coveted boosters to be offered to
all over 18s in a bid to halt the spread
the express has the same story saying
covet booster jabs will save christmas
the telegraph leads with violence
erupting after new wave of covert cases
spread at lightning speed in europe
the metro has a picture of the prime
minister
maskless on a train as daily covert
cases top 40 000.
the financial times reports u.s pentagon
scientists were caught off guard after a
chinese missile was fired
the guardian leads with the growing
concerns of a government backbench
rebellion amid a social care revolt
the daily mirror has an investigation
into fur farms in
finland and the daily star reports
forecasters are at war with some saying
we are in for a deep winter freeze while
the met office says it'll be warm
and we are joined tonight by salma shah
and steve richards good evening to you
both let's start with the uh telegraph
and their headline their rage across
europe as covid rules trigger riots and
there's been disquiet and disorder in
brussels in the netherlands um they've
also been violent scenes in austria
italy croatia denmark and switzerland
over the weekend salma
yes this is really concerning because
obviously we are looking at countries
that are in most cases quite similar to
our own
and where we are seeing cases rise we
know that the uk case numbers have been
um
quite high for for a long time although
we are not seeing the hospitalizations
and seriousness uh associated with the
the first and second waves so i think
being able to monitor and watch very
closely what's happening in europe is
going to be a top priority of the
government but also trying to understand
whether there's going to be a different
kind of variant that comes up that could
potentially put the vaccine at risk i
think all of these things alongside the
violence is something that we need to
assess and look at you know because we
do not want to have similar scenes here
uh if we go into more restrictions
yes um but steve meanwhile the health
secretary here is saying that uh because
of the opening up during the summer
months we are not experiencing these
conditions and we're going to be
sticking to to plan a
well whether it's
it's it's because of the booster job
isn't it the opening up in the summer
was a uh quite a reckless thing to do in
the way it was done but the
uh
the booster jab uh might be a protective
shield uh in the uk we've had more
booster jabs than in the countries
experiencing the possibility of more
constraints uh have uh had um and we
also had quite a bit of a wave ourselves
in the summer and early autumn um but i
think what is worrying is there are two
things going on really there is there
has been the hope
here obviously and across europe that we
were going to be through a lot of this
and certainly if you go out and about in
london these days it's as if it's not
around
and therefore when the possibility of
constraints return after all this time
where this pandemic has hovered over us
some people are going to get angry as we
are seeing in parts of europe but the
governments there really have no choice
um you've got to act when it's spreading
again
like a fire and that's clearly what's uh
happening in parts of europe and this is
the response of people who had hoped
they were through the worst of it and
it's it's so so we're at another
fragile moment in this dark saga
and salma when we see scenes like this
in europe and the the numbers of um kobe
patients are increasing at such a rapid
rate
does it then focus our attention on
perhaps how slack we are now with things
like mask wearing
i think it definitely draws attention to
that and you know the idea that this is
a personal choice you know when there
are when there is the potential that the
government can mandate it for you i
think you know people should really
consider that uh you know that at some
point it's going to stop being a
personal choice
um but there are other things other than
mark wearing i think that are helping
the government and i don't think we can
discount the fact that this summer
opening actually may have helped create
a lot more natural immunity amongst our
population and also that there are other
things in terms of antiviral treatments
that have been procured in what is still
a very competitive market globally
because everybody wants to have these
treatments that have also assisted so i
think it's a lot more complicated i
think where people need to make that
personal choice
about um mask wearing you know they
should but i think at some point um they
have to acknowledge that you know all of
these things can be mandated and i think
the government needs to be clearer about
that and i think they're trying to be
which is why they're trying to push the
booster jab um and push those people who
are over 40 who just opened into this
cohort to go and get that
but speaking of mars uh steve the the
metro is accusing the the prime minister
of having well his own mask slipping him
being photographed on a train not
wearing a mask and they're suggesting
that he has contempt for his own advice
on
face coverings
yeah i think he does um that's the only
conclusion you can reach when you see
him at a crowded glasgow conference next
to elderly people not wearing one in a
hospital not wearing one on a train not
wearing one
and um he clearly doesn't believe in it
or else he would wear them and um it
sends out in my view a terrible and
irresponsible signal i just got back a
few hours ago from a big match at
tottenham hotspur in north london and in
the indoor bit people were crammed in
you know queueing up for drinks and
stuff i didn't see a single person with
a mask amongst the crowd the stewards
all were but not and um when you have
that signal from the top and he's
clearly decided you know he can't be
bothered he doesn't believe in it he's a
you know libertarian it's up to me i
don't think i want to wear one um and it
it is it is really
irresponsible sama what do you make of
this mixed messaging
i do think that there needs to be a bit
more consistency at the top of
government because you know as i say the
personal choice thing it's fine if you
feel that you're
well enough to make that personal choice
but actually this is going to be a
government decision ultimately of when
they when they may need to invoke plan b
if indeed that does happen you know all
of this stuff is going to be mandated so
i think a bit of guidance in the form of
um you know pictures from the prime
minister would actually be quite helpful
um but you know he he is going against
his own advice in terms of crowded
places and i understand that for some of
us i mean i i sometimes forget to put my
mask on if i'm in a crowded space or
maybe i don't feel the need to but i'm
not the person that's making the
decisions and trying to enforce this and
inflict this in some cases on other
people so i i do think you need
consistency at the top
staying with covert test and trace is
back in the headlines uh steve and the
guardian um pointing to the fact that
it's still costing more than a million
pounds a day um that's been spent on
private consultants
yeah well this has been a running theme
and clearly still not uh
resolved uh some companies have done and
continue to make
a lot of money out of this and i think
one of the themes going forward
it's become one already of course is um
use of money uh contracts who's made
money out of this
um
it's while we're still in it the the
pandemic it's it's one of the themes uh
but you know if we do get out of it um
the way these things were arranged uh
will have to be looked at in
considerable uh detail um i'm just
looking at the headline now a million a
day
for consultants uh trust that test and
trace consultants not actually the
mechanism itself um yeah well that's as
say being a sort of ongoing thing i
haven't read the full details of what
these consultants do precisely but it
does seem extravagant
salma just got a minute to um talk about
another story in the the guardian um and
this is a warning from
tory mps to the prime minister take us
into this
yes well this is about uh how the cap uh
formula for social care is looking to be
changed i haven't looked at the detail
of what the what the cap um
is going to look like with this uh new
measurement
um but uh there are lots of tory mps
that are saying that actually it
affects disproportionately poorer
pensioners which means that they will be
facing the same cap on on social care
costs as their richer counterparts and
if that is the case we've already seen
that the conservative backbench is very
capable of rebellion on big issues um
you know especially around sort of
expensive second jobs with mps um so
this is definitely looking like a
headache for the prime minister and
number 10 coming down the track yeah so
the the detailed department of health
and social care called alarm last week
when it revealed it would calculate the
85 000 cap on lifetime care costs in a
way that left tens of thousands of
england's poorest pensioners paying the
same as wealthier people as you
suggested